[Música]
escala en París Aída Palau
Bienvenidos a todos a este programa de
radio Francia internacional y de France
24 París abre sus puertas al sector
agroalimentario mundial con el salón
Internacional de la Alimentación una
especie de escaparate donde Los
profesionales del sector presentan las
apuestas y tendencias innovadoras para
el futuro sin perder de vista uno de los
credos de hoy la sostenibilidad Hoy hace
escala en París un productor y
exportador que trae productos de chile
Lionel galís Muchísimas gracias por
estar con nosotros bienvenido Lionel
galís que es Francés pero que lleva
mucho tiempo en Chile 20 años dedicado a
la apicultura y a la agricultura
forestal en Chile nos explicarán
enseguida que quiere decir con su
empresa saber
maritim sabores de los Andes marítimos
exporta principalmente miel de los Andes
y de la Patagonia y también morchelas
vuelve el salón tras cuatro años de
ausencia por la pandemia 7 empresas el
88% internacionales y con un contexto un
tanto peculiar no el alzada de precios
crisis de materias primas Cuál es el
estado de ánimo que se respira en el
salón Es la primera vez que usted
participa para la primera vez
participando este salón pero con un
enfoque muy particular como lo dijiste
hay muchas empresas que efectivamente ya
vienen en este salón y era la
oportunidad para nosotros compro chile
la institución chilena de promoción de
los productos chilenos un poquito
enfocar nuestros productos del chileno y
particularmente del Bosque nativo Así
que la meta era de presentar este bosque
forestal a los empresarios del mundo Y
cómo les ha ido nos ha ido muy bien
porque generalmente la gente no sabían
Qué tipo de producto podíamos salir o
extraer de este bosque nativo como ya
bien lo dijiste mieles morchelas pero
nosotros productos que se quedan te
representan una artesanía de gente que
saben trabajar productos y que ofrecen
Sabores distintas y con valores
sustentables muy muy apreciables
justamente por qué decidió dedicarse a
la apicultura y también a esa
agricultura forestal en Chile la verdad
es que yo al inicio Yo Soy ingeniero
civil gerente de obra en una empresa
grande de construcción y cuando llegamos
en Chile en 1999 con mi familia nos
encontramos con un país y con bosques
nativos muy maravillosos me encanta las
setas los champiñones y de inmediato
encontramos un interés de trabajar con
la conaf que es la corporación nacional
forestal de chile para participar en
programa de reforestación estabilización
de suelo y protección del Bosque nativo
Y en este mismo bosque nativo al inicio
de los años 2000 encontré mochilas y me
di cuenta que a unos árboles tenían
mucha floración y Pinterest también para
la apicultura y Así que decidimos
invertir allá hablan de modos
artesanales y respetuosos con los ciclos
de la naturaleza En qué se diferencia la
apicultura chilena de otras Bueno lo que
diría Es que la potencia de la
avicultura chilena reside en su bosque
nativo porque justamente con la
institución chilena con AF hay una ley
de protección de esos bosques nativos y
esos bosques nativos
se encuentran muchos árboles melíferas y
la apicultura chilena al 90% se dedica
efectivamente a extraer su miel de los
bosques nativos puede ser un poquito lo
contrario por ejemplo en Francia Yo
también tengo algunas colmenas pero mis
colmenas se van a encontrar en campos de
la banda en campos de girasol en campos
de canola que son mucho más extensivos y
que no salen del Bosque nativo y ahí
Efectivamente es una una diferencia
importante si bien también en Francia
existen mieles del Bosque nativo
obviamente según cifras oficiales hay
más de un millón 350.000 colmenas en
chile y casi 9.600 apicultores casi el
20% de ellos exportan
hay una cifra oficial en el 2021 se
exportaron 3.320 toneladas de miel por
un monto de 13,8 millones yo la pregunta
que le hago es la exportaciones vital
para la apicultura chilena sí es vital
porque efectivamente con este número de
apicultor hay que también entender que
la apicultura chilena es bastante
productiva las abejas están muy sanas no
hay poco enfermedad con la con esas
abejas no tenemos plagas Y entonces cada
Colmena produce un buen promedio de lo
contrario que pasa en Europa y entonces
el mercado chileno finalmente produce en
exceso unas mieles extraordinarias pero
las cifras que diste es una cifra de
exportación postco y durante el covid la
miel chilena no se pudo exportar pero
Miren el mercado chileno consumió mucho
más miel
[Música]
respetando a los años pasados yo tengo
cifras que hasta los 12.000 toneladas se
pudieron exportar en 2015-2016 y existe
esta potencia realmente dicen que la
comercialización de sus productos
la exportación garantiza la protección
de los bosques nativos de los Andes y de
la y de la Patagonia En qué medida lo
hace porque claro estamos hablando de
que la exportación Bueno hay que
transportar no la miel de
o sea y hay que cruzar de chile Europa y
hay que cruzar el canal de Panamá y ese
cliente en mi caso particular hay que
cruzar todo
efectivamente todo un océano en estos
tiempos de sostenibilidad nos podemos
preguntar es sostenible que en Europa se
consuma miel chilena bueno La respuesta
es sí obviamente
el interés justamente de tener una
artesanía sostenible en los bosques
nativo permite mantener esos bosques
nativos yo tengo que hacer mucha
pedagogía con mis clientes para
justamente explicar el interés primero
que todo las mieles chilenas son únicas
en el mundo los árboles que
utilizamos para sacar la miel son
endémicos de esta de este bosque no se
encuentran en otra parte del mundo pues
está hablando de árboles de humo tiyaca
tepuquia y etcétera entonces a mantener
una artesanía responsable permite
eficiente mantener esos bosques luego la
persona va a preguntar que efectivamente
el transporte va a emitir
equidad adelante de carbono en el océano
por ejemplo cuando yo voy a exportar un
contenedor de 12 toneladas de miel voy a
emitir en el en la atmósfera 10 tonelada
equivalente de carbono Pero uno tiene
que entender que el bosque nativo que se
necesi para producir los 12 toneladas
representan casi 20 millones de árboles
que consumen por fotosíntesis 10.000
veces la cantidad que hemos emitido para
hacer el transporte es decir que la
relación es de 1 a 10.000 para el inicio
de la planeta y por eso mi discurso es
decir consumen productos que salen de
los bosques nativos será bueno para la
planeta Y además que son muy específicos
si no hubiera abejas no habría bosque
no
sería diferente no habría no habría
tanta biodiversidad porque efectivamente
las abejas o los insectos polinizadores
participan efectivamente a difundir las
semillas y afectivamente mantener la
biodiversidad es decir que podríamos
mucho de nuestros vegetales sin las
abejas y sin los insectos polinizadores
porque no solamente son las abejas pero
las abejas el medio más importante
obviamente hay preocupación
a nivel mundial no que si las abejas se
mueren Pues nosotros nos vamos a morir
No porque el ecosistema en el que
vivimos se va a morir
la disminución de las colmenas es un
fenómeno mundial
y su declive puede justamente provocar
escasez de alimentos
escasez de plantas medicinales y
animales herbívoros hace unos meses vi
que los apicultores chilenos protestaron
ante la moneda para pedir políticas
públicas para pedir ayudas no Cuál es la
situación sabemos que a nivel mundial es
muy preocupante en el caso de chile Cuál
es la situación la situación en Chile es
un poquito distinta a lo que piden a los
apicultores chilenos pienso yo es
efectivamente agruparse como un
sindicato mucho más potente para
justamente recibir ayudas capacitaciones
para justamente ya hacer su trabajo de
manera mucho más responsable mucho más
sustentable y de manera también mucho
más productiva
el problema así que antes de la
apicultura mundial cambio de clima
plagas
herbicidas pesticidas finalmente no nos
afecta tanto en Chile porque de nuevo
estamos ubicados en los bosques nativos
al 90% justamente de la producción
chilena pero lo que falta efectivamente
a la apicultura chilena es toda esa
parte de capacitación para mejorar su
producto y poder justamente exportar sus
excedentes y qué mejor forma de
agruparse
en sindicatos otro problema que había
visto que no sé hasta qué punto afecta
digamos al Bosque que es donde usted
trabaja la miel es la escasez de flores
que pone en riesgo la supervivencia de
las abejas en Chile no sé si afecta a
las regiones o alguna regiones en
concreto y Parece ser que el motivo
principal es la gran sequía no que
aparece el país
efectivamente en chile se nota
particularmente de chile es un país ahí
norte sur muy largo la producción de la
miel chilena ya abarca casi 3.000
kilómetros de largo y efectivamente las
flores y los árboles dependen mucho de
las lluvias y las condiciones climáticas
chile como toda parte del mundo sufre de
este cambio climático y de las sequías Y
eso puede tener eficiente un impacto muy
grande en las colmenas y en la Perdida
de las abejas
le quería preguntar también que en el
salón Internacional de la Alimentación
se intenta innovar y reflexionar sobre
la alimentación del futuro le quería
preguntar cómo ve usted el plato del
mañana el plato de mañana Mira la verdad
es que tenemos que tener un balance bien
equilibrado entre lo que va a
representar
la carne
los legumbres y efectivamente los
postres bueno como francés ya no se
puede terminar una cena sin queso y sin
postre pero los postres es efectivamente
Tendremos que ya pensar en incluir mucho
más miel adentro y sacar el azúcar
porque efectivamente no hay nada mejor
que la miel para para hacer un postre
además de su sabor los azúcares que
contiene es mucho mejor así que
efectivamente hay que trabajar en este
equilibrio pero sin ser tampoco
extremistas y decir no más Carne no más
que esos no hay que efectivamente dejar
la oportunidad pero hacerlo de manera
mucho más sustentable efectivamente
usted ha notado esa
mentalidad digamos en el salón de que se
tiene que ir hacia lo sostenible o
sustentable
Ayer ya fue bien sorprendido porque yo
probé unas carnes entrego mía que no son
carne porque son 100% de planta y
son Realmente muy ricas la textura el
sabor el parecer parece salchicha
solamente Tendremos que transparentar
bien a los clientes lo que tienen en el
plato no hay que engañar a la gente voy
a regresar al tema de la miel por
ejemplo de manera general los
apicultores se quejan que existen en el
mundo mieles falsas Y entonces por qué
Por ejemplo en Europa se permite
importar en Europa mieles que son jarabe
que no son mieles que no nunca dieron
una abeja entonces de la misma manera
Tendremos que bien transparentar para
decir a la gente eso no es carne es
planta Y eso puede sustituirla Por
supuesto que sí Bueno pues muchísimas
gracias Lionel galis por haber estado
con nosotros y le deseamos muchísimo
éxito y muchas gracias a todos ustedes
por habernos acompañado ya saben que nos
pueden seguir por internet también en rf
y mundo.com y en francés 24.com Hasta
pronto amigos
[Música]